all right
okay we're rolling this is on throwing
and catching anything I think you can
get it get it get it copied up is all I
need to get it up it's all I need where
the back are you
and we got Logan I like driving and also
recording a beta at the same time
because I'm very talented you've got
some raw talent try to start off work
and I'm gonna get jiggy with it and I'm
gonna honey I'm home
do you bring the groceries in oh yeah
here's the staircase staircase right
here staircase oh my god she was like
Dumbledore when he fell down that Canyon
and there's no going back
she was like your virginity when it's
gone she was like oh my god I got I got
my Godzilla right now because that's my
mission in life where oh my god Logan
I'm here at YouTube space la we like
totally need to film here [ __ ] shut the
F up Jenelle are you [ __ ] kidding me
right now I like we totally should film
there because we're basically like
royalty and so I think you should also
steal something because essentially it
is ours
no again I figuring it out I'm gonna
still that's bean bag
hey this is the ice cream this is
[ __ ]
I get a little bored is your head sugar
it's just coffee and it's not a big deal
I need upcoming yeah they're perfect
that that's perfect
have you guys seen a new Kevin James
movie where he's like dammit dammit
alright yellow and blue are you having a
seizure nope nope nope no but that's the
thing thing oh yeah that's great well
yeah what are you okay nope maybe this
time put some work
put some more heart and soul into it no
again I'm in my bra oh my god you stupid
[ __ ] put on some clothing you know we
have people coming over again you dare
me to go to cozy coffee and just my bra
and panties how much how much would you
pay how much would you bet me five bet
you five what like what like five STDs
and like right now I can't even deal
with you like I have to go I think I
have to go I might even just turn around
I may just turn around Hey ladies turn
around you were like hey thank you Lisa
ain't want you to know that I am a
selfless friend and I already came here
I didn't turn around even though I know
you're gonna be in like one of those
fancy push-up bras
then I know what your boobs are better
than mine but it's like okay I'm just
gonna get over it because I realize that
sometimes my ass looks good but today I
didn't wear those jeans that make you
jealous okay it's like I'm coming in now
so just like just like get over yourself
[ __ ] done like put on a towel do you
think yeah yeah is that because now we
can do close-ups right yeah okay you're
good for